Let me ask you this personally, Ali. Do
you think now you got a beautiful little
sister over there? I saw her. She's a
freaking adorable. Mhm. If a grown man
tried to come and say, "Hey man, what's
up with your sister?" A 29-year-old,
30-year-old, 40-year-old, 50-year-old,
do you think that that's okay?
Well, she's not above the age of
puberty, so no. Okay, so that's the
puberty limit. So, it's wrong for men to
try to engage with girls who are
pre-pubescent, who have not reached
puberty, right?
Mhm. All right, cool. So, that's what
I'm going to show you. I'm going to show
you that it's taught in the Quran that
men are allowed to have these relations
with girls who have not even reached
puberty yet. Who have not reached
puberty? I I want to see this, okay?
>> so this is tough. All right, here we go.
So, this is chapter 65, verse four. Oh,
I have that one memorized. Good. It's
about divorce, right? Yeah. You actually
have it memorized? You got it in You got
it You got it memorized in Arabic?
>> entire thing in I have the entire thing
in Arabic. I know it from mind. Maybe
the the what's it called the the
translation, I'm not I'm not going to
have the whole thing, but I can like
read it in Arabic.
>> You can recite it in Arabic. That's
beautiful. That's dope, man. And those
of your women
as have passed the age of monthly
courses,
for them the iddah, if you have doubts,
is three months. Now, do you you
familiar with what the iddah is, right?
Yeah. So, it's the waiting period before
It is the waiting period after a divorce
before woman can move on to the to the
to the next man to make sure she's not
pregnant. Yeah. All right. Okay, cool.
So, for the women who's too old to
menstruate, right? They're past the age
of monthly courses,
their iddah is three months. And for
those who have no courses, I don't like
to read, you know, like you already know
me. I don't like to use parentheses cuz
that's them putting it in there, but on
this one they are correct, the ones who
are still immature. But look, it says,
"And for those who have no courses."
Now, you know this in the Arabic. The
words are lam yahidna, right? Which
means that they have never had their
periods yet. They haven't had it yet.
Mhm.
So, their their iddah is three months
also.
Mhm. Right?
And for those who are pregnant, their
iddah is until they deliver and who else
and whoever Allah, you know, fears Allah
keeps his duty, he'll make it easy for
him. Okay, so three categories of women.
The women who are too old to menstruate,
right? They're past the age, so this is
menopause is what they call menopause.
They're past the age of of of having
periods. The second category
>> [snorts]
>> are the ones who have not had their
periods yet.
But
>> They're too young. Thank you. They're
pre-pubescent. They haven't hit puberty
yet, all right? Their iddah is three
months also. And then you have the third
category, the pregnant women. Their
iddah is until they have the baby. So,
the second category is the one we're
focusing on, the ones who are too young
to menstruate. They are They haven't
They haven't had their menstruation yet.
So, the Quran is saying you can divorce
these girls, you can marry and divorce
these girls even before they have
puberty.
Mhm.
Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> Nothing wrong with that so far? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, I could see what you're
talking about.
Okay, but it gets worse, okay? Because
someone Some might say, "Well, it's okay
to to, you know, come up with a marriage
contract.
You can do a marriage contract with a
young girl, but doesn't mean that you,
you know, do the dingy dingy
yet until she reaches puberty." Some
might say that. Like you don't You can
marry a young girl, but you have to wait
until she hits puberty before you
consummate or make the marriage final
by, you know, doing the thing thing.
Right? Now, let me show you that that's
absolutely incorrect because here's the
important detail
that they have an iddah. They have an
iddah. They have a waiting period.
Which means that their husbands slept
with them. The iddah is to make sure the
girl's not pregnant.
Mhm. Now, let me show you this.
In the Quran Or okay. I'm sorry. What
did you say?
I was just going to say that like so, if
you marry somebody, right? You could
still not do anything and you could
divorce them. You still have it.
They couldn't They could have not done
anything. You're still going to have it.
Not the iddah. Watch.
So, watch what the Quran says. Now, it's
crazy cuz the Quran actually literally
addresses this. So, it says, "O you who
believe." This is chapter 33, verse 49.
>> "O you who believe,
when you marry believing women
and then divorce them before
you have sexual intercourse with them,
Mhm.
no iddah
have you to count in respect of them.
So, give them a present and set them
free."
All right?
So, if you are divorcing a woman, you're
divorcing a female
before you've done anything, before
you've had sexual intercourse with them,
then there is no iddah for them.
So, you only have an iddah
if you've done something.
All right.
That's
>> it's tough, huh?
>> [clears throat]
>> Yeah, it's very tough.
So, the Quran is here, bro.
The Quran is teaching here
that you are able to marry
and not just marry,
but even have
intercourse. Oops, where did I go?
Even have intercourse
with girls before they even reach
puberty. So, let me show you what the
standard was
according to the Bible. This is 1
Corinthians chapter 7, verse 36.
"But if any man thinks he is behaving
improperly toward his virgin,
if she is past the flower of her youth
and thus it must be,
let him do what he wishes.
He does not sin. Let them marry."
So, according to the Bible,
the girl has to be past the flower of
her youth. Not just when she hits
puberty, she got to be past that
in order for them to be married. That
could have been, but that also, if you
think about it, that that could have
been the standard at that time. But then
later on it could have gotten younger
and younger as years went by. So, you're
>> I didn't say that I wasn't trying to say
that it was the standard for all of time
before that. I'm just saying in that
specific time, that age, people were
getting people were as low as I believe
12 were getting married to
obviously older guys So, do you think
>> it was the standard. I I hear you. So,
are you saying that uh
that God's standard of morality changes
with time or does God's standard of
morality stand above culture?
I think that
in my personal in my personal belief
or not in my personal belief, but in my
own sense of knowledge, I could say that
during that time
it may have been the it may have been
the standard at that specific moment in
time,
but now The standard for who? For God or
for the culture? For for God Not for
God, sorry, for the um For the culture?
>> at that time, for the people at that
time.
>> Yeah, so you're talking about cultural
relativism. That's when basically what's
what's normalized is basically what's
okay. Like, for example, one time
uh you know, the slavery of Africans was
normalized and it was okay.
Would you say that that was right or
wrong even though it was normal?
Can you repeat the question?
Was it Was it morally right? Was it
morally good uh back in the day, back in
the 1800s, 1700s, when Africans were
being
um
kidnapped from their homes and forced
into slavery? How was that?
>> wrong. Okay, but that was that was the
cultural norm, though.
You see what I'm saying?
>> for them to be for them to be um for
them to be taken and put into Yeah, and
that was culturally the norm for America
and other whole countries as well. That
was culturally normal. They would go,
kidnap the Africans, and force them into
slavery to work on the lands.
But I don't think but I I don't think
that that God
I don't know how to explain this, but I
was told this growing up that Allah he
knows every single thing that happens on
the earth. He knows everything's going
to happen by day by day. Mhm. And
it's it's And the way that my dad
explained it because the way that my dad
explained it was that it was a game. Uh
like you could say that life is a game
and you're you're trying to do the right
things to
A test.
>> enter Yeah, like a almost like a test
and you want to get You want to do the
right things so that you can enter
heaven. That's but that's not what I'm
mentioning, brother. What I'm what I'm
I'm I'm asking you something Like I want
you to focus on something very specific
here.
That
that
there was there's something that you're
saying
is [snorts] wrong
that was actually culturally the norm,
which is slavery, the slavery of
Africans. You agree that that was evil.
Mhm. However, it was
it was
>> the norm.
As was the as was the
as was people are younger younger age
people getting married to older people
and also having intercourse with them.
And that also was wrong. That That also
isn't a good
>> Very good. There we go. That's what I
wanted to get to. So, even though
something can be culturally the norm,
it can still be wrong what they're
doing, right?
Yeah.
So, I'm asking this. Even if this was
culturally the norm to marry and sleep
with young girls before they reach
puberty, is that okay?
No, of course not.
All right. And so, this is
>> But I have a question, though. I have a
question.
>> Okay.
If that was the
That may have been the norm at that
time. And to us now, obviously that's
going to be like, "Whoa, he's 30
sleeping with a 14-year-old. That
doesn't make sense. That's not okay."
At that time, that was how it was. No
matter how wrong it was, that's how it
was at that time. Right.
>> Now, obviously, if Now, if we if we had
brought that same that same logic what
they were doing into this time, it would
be completely unacceptable. You also
have to think about how they were
thinking at that time, right?
>> Listen. Listen.
If you if you acknowledge that something
is wrong,
even if it's even if it's normal at
these people's in these people's time,
it's morally wrong. Would God succumb to
the cultural norm, or will he stand
above the cultural norm and say, "Don't
do this"?
Okay.
For example, here's a here's a good
example that a lot of Muslims bring up,
actually. It's a actually good one.
Here's something good Muhammad did. It
was a It was culturally normal for like
the pagan Arabs around around his time,
uh when they had daughters, to bury
their daughters alive, right? You You
guys familiar with this?
Uh I was not. Oh, wow.
>> Can you repeat it? Can you repeat it?
Well, there there was a there there was
when they didn't want their daughters
and stuff like that, these pagan Arabs,
they would they would bury their
daughters alive. They would bury their
infant babies alive.
Muhammad came out and said, "Don't do
that. This is evil."
>> Right.
Okay? Now, this was normal at the time.
That was That was the cultural normal
thing to do. This is what they did.
But Muhammad was able to stand above
that and say, "No, you shouldn't do
this. This is wrong." Even though it was
culturally the norm.
So, I'm only using that as an example of
saying that
that
morally uh
objective morality, there are things
that are moral, right? That we know are
right and wrong, regardless of time,
regardless of of culture,
regardless of situation. There are
certain things that are just wrong,
period.
Period. It doesn't matter where you are,
what time, what era, it's wrong. Just
like sleeping with a creepy messing
girl, sleeping with a girl who had has
not reached puberty yet, she's immature
mentally and physically, that's wrong
regardless of what era you live in.
Wouldn't you agree?
Yeah.
Okay. I agree, too. I'm glad you agree
with that.
So, here's the point. Since we all three
of us agree with that, and so and Ali
does, too,
we all agree with that.
We disagree with this Quran, then.
Because the Quran is giving you
permission to do that. Um I actually got
a I just looked up a video. I I just
looked up sort of sort of al-Kahf
explained.
But I'm going to make sure I'm going to
talk to talk to you about this probably
later, but what it said there is
so, when people when girls start
puberty, like when they like start,
the period isn't their only sign. So,
it's saying when they start puberty,
you're allowed to do it, though they may
have not had their period yet.
Okay. So, let's go ahead. I'm glad that
you were starting going to explanation.
You guys You guys know who
>> need to go I need to go ahead and start
praying. We have Asr prayer. So, I'm
going to go ahead and sign off. Just
want to thank you again for obviously
letting me on and
um thank you for the knowledge. I will
definitely definitely obviously learn a
little bit more about it and hopefully
be able to come back at a different
time.
>> Yeah. Uh but until then, please have a
beautiful day. You, too, man.
Yeah. You, too, man. Thanks for coming
on. And Ali, you got to go, too, don't
you?
I'm just going to finish this question,
cuz I want to hear what you were going
to say, and then I'll head out. All
right, good. So, let's go into the You
know who Ibn Kathir is?
Tafsir Ibn Kathir?
>> Ibn Kathir? No. Okay. Well, in Sunni
Islam, he's one of the most respected
commentators of the Quran.
Okay? Mhm. His name's Ibn Kathir. When
you come when you come back to the
video, make sure you you note this down,
okay? Ibn Kathir. Look him up. You can
even look him up right now and see and
see how respected he is. Authority.
>> So, we're going to go to his tafsir, his
commentary, his explanation. He breaks
this stuff down.
The iddah of those in menopause and
those who do not have menses.
Allah, the exalted, clarifies the
waiting period of the woman in
menopause,
and that is the one
whose menstruation has stopped due to
her older age.
Her iddah is 3 months instead of the
three monthly cycles for those who
menstruate,
which is based upon the ayah in chapter
2, verse 228.
The same for the young
who have not reached the years of
menstruation. Their iddah is 3 months
like like those in menopause.
This is the meaning of his saying, "And
for those who have no courses."
So, this is talking about
not that uh
not that old that maybe they just
haven't reached puberty because, you
know, maybe they're old enough, but
maybe they just haven't bled yet. No.
These are girls who haven't even reached
the years of menstruation. They're too
young.
>> is a long cycle. I mean, you could be I
mean, I know I know of people who are 14
and still haven't had it yet. So, but
they've definitely reached puberty, and
they should have started when they were
like nine. So, yeah, that's definitely
years.
So, they've reached the years of
menstruation. Like they They They're old
enough. They've reached the year of
having it, but they still haven't had
one yet.
>> Exactly. So, they're
>> in their case, they're
So, in their case, say they got married,
and if they got divorced,
or say they got married, it would have
been after puberty, but they wouldn't
have menstruated yet. And they could
have done something, and they would
still have to wait, even though they've
never had menstruation. Yeah, so uh
apart from talking about anomalies or
health anomalies like that, we're
talking about
uh the ones who have not reached the
years of menstruation, the ones who have
are just They're just too young.
Like he he goes into He quotes a hadith,
actually, on this.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, here he goes. This has been
reported. This right here is where we're
at.
This has been reported from Sa'id bin
Jubair,
and it is the view preferred by Ibn
Jarir,
and this is the
more obvious meaning.
This is the more obvious meaning.
Supporting this view is what is reported
from Ubayy ibn Ka'b,
that he said, "O Allah's messenger,
some women were not mentioned in the
Quran,
the young, the old, and the pregnant."
All right?
So, everybody understands this
to be talking about
young girls, man.
Mhm. Before Before they matured.
All right. I can I can see where you're
coming from. I'll make sure to ask
somebody. Yeah.
Come on back, man. Thank you for letting
me on here.
Thank you for giving me all these
because I believe that
I'd love to go on more about how even if
this wouldn't be true,
Christianity is a whole 'nother can of
worms I want to open up. Absolutely. So,
uh all right. Thank you for letting me
on. I'll make sure to ask somebody about
this, and I really hope in the future
I'll be able to talk to you about it.
>> You can come in at any time, man. Just
hit me up. All right, guys. That was our
guy Ali,
his friend uh Abraham. Great
conversation with these young guys, man.
Beautiful. Pray for them.